oh là là regardez regardez bonjour
à la porte pas beaucoup de moins en
moins comment il marche ce journal en ce
moment là
on vend 65000 on va vraiment 65000 le
maximum c'était quoi dans les années 70
Cavana on était jusqu'à 160 000 en
quelle année à la mort de Pompidou vous
rappelez
dans les 150 à peu près régulièrement
on a bien vendu à la mort de Mitterrand
à la mort de Pompidou et il y a pas
encore la mort de la mort tragique
j'ai inventé en quelle année le beauf 74
tu l'as exploité mais pas tant que ça
finalement tu as pas été
regarde tous les films qui ont été faits
à partir de personnages justement ça
peut être des réussites tu sais l'état
même les Tintin et tout ça il s'est mis
en animation mais avec un personnage
réel c'était c'était pas réussi un
animation de la proposer non non voilà
ce qu'il a fait de l'animation
Guilhem qui disait alors toi tu fais des
dessins avec les dessins après tu fais
des livres avec les livres tu fais des
pièces avec tes pièces tu fais des films
je suis un peu fait tout ça mais pas
beaucoup quand même
fait du théâtre
je ne veux pas mourir idiot elle ne
pense qu'à ça ça c'était réussi et puis
j'ai fait des films avec Aldo maccion
c'est parce que j'ai fait de mieux mais
t'as pas pu choisir tes comédiens aussi
j'ai même pas cherché à les choisir je
me laisse faire
c'est un trade caractère
donc il vaut mieux que je reste
dessinateur et je ne fasse que ça parce
que là personne n'intervient je me
laisse pas faire
de l'armée ils sont toujours le deuxième
budget de l'État derrière l'éducation
quand on parle d'économie de l'État on
ne parle jamais du budget de l'armée
c'est ça qui mais qu'est-ce que tu veux
depuis 50 ans on dit ça et c'est vrai ce
que tu dis personne enfin personne
personne n'est indigné par ça le truc
qui m'a dit aussi c'est que la gauche
soit plus la gauche qui est plus de
programme de gauche que la gauche se
battent plus avec la droite parce que
c'est pas qu'il y a un consensus c'est
qu'ils ont l'impression de rien pouvoir
faire du coup on laisse aux autres faire
les conneries et donc on va revenir au
pouvoir non pas parce qu'on a un super
programme mais parce que les autres ont
fait des conneries et une fois que la
gauche sera au pouvoir la droite
reviendra au pouvoir parce que ils vont
espérer que la gauche fasse des
conneries parce que la gauche n'est pas
complètement contre la loi du marché par
exemple
ils ont renoncé sur plein de points
c'est tout comme c'est l'essentiel de
la bagarre
socialiste qui est plus imparti moi je
j'aimais autant j'ai pas de sympathie
particulière pour le Parti socialiste
mais mais j'aimais quand le Parti
socialiste on va reparti maintenant ça
me fait marrer maintenant je préfère en
rigoler parce que sinon c'est c'est à
pleurer il y a la mondialisation qui a
pris une importance qu'il n'y avait pas
il y a 30 ans comme tu dis on peut pas
ignorer le milliard de Chinois qui qui
va fabriquer tous nos objets là et
comment veux-tu tu peux pas te rétrécir
sur tes frontières tu es perdant et le
programme de la cible qui ont changé
aussi avant quand tu t'appelles sur un
homme politique français on sait tout le
monde savait qui c'était maintenant
quand on tape sur l'homme politique pour
lui reprocher quelque chose ah bah c'est
pas moi c'est l'Europe quand c'est pas
l'Europe c'est des Chinois ou quand
c'est pas les Chinois c'est les
Américains ont commencé par les
Américains est-ce qu'on peut dire que la
situation nous échappe
oui ça nous glisse entre les doigts oui
mais à l'époque savonnette on sait plus
très bien comment accrocher les choses
politiques c'est pareil avant dans les
années 60 tu leur tapais dans les
couilles ils disaient maintenant tu leur
tapes dans les couilles on continue à
faire
tu rencontres rien et ils ont plus rien
ils s'en foutent enfin ce qui leur fait
plaisir c'est d'apparaître dans un média
quel qu'il soit même si même si on dit
du mal de il reçoive leur service de
presse ils sont contents il y a une page
sur eux le mec s'il existe pas pour toi
quand le service de presse de Sarkozy te
dit de tous les jours de venir le voir
parce qu'il va dire un truc alors que
tout le monde le déteste mais tout le
monde doit voir tu sais si tout d'un
coup les gens disent non ça c'est pas
vraiment de l'info il y a des trucs au
Liberia il y a un footballeur qui est
sur le point d'être président avec
d'ancien meurtriers qui vont lui servir
de rire on peut peut-être bon au
football mais il faut peut-être
s'interroger non ça va être plus malin
marrant de faire Sarkozy parce que là au
moins on se dit les gens vont comprendre
l'Auberge de la verge jeûne c'est
d'envoyer mon cheval et fantasque comme
ma masque je courut droite au corso en
chantant dans la brosse que ce refrain
de Caruso quand j'étais en dentelle en
bon état je passais pour voir ma belle
faire semer les placards dans la rue
l'accue une belle scénarina me fait
signe qu'elle les dignes d'entrer dans
la danse avec moi je l'emporte à de mi
morte elle tombe dans mes bras et sa
mère en colère nous menace s'écrit
là-bas ramenez-moi donc ma fille
cavalier chevalier de guerre je suis
veuve et son famille je suis vieille je
suis fatigué
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu